[Music]
okay ready for operation Phoenix Arizona
hey nice if you've been out here long
about for a little bit freeze
a circumstance we got you down here
I actually was brought down from Phoenix
by I'm a guy who while later found out
was a pen
yeah brought me down here promised me
the leg I was a little bit of nice house
and like he's gonna take care of
everything and I'm a heroin addict and
he was like I can give you all the air
when you need and then I was like cool
and he had a few other girls with him
and they're like yeah everything's great
it's fine it's fun and then so we drive
down and end up in Compton I still don't
remember the exact streets but he pulls
up to this like like shack house like
shanty house like they had in like like
New York City during the Great
Depression like it's made out of like
big pieces of wood like nailed together
and like it's like a tarp as a roof and
like the first thing that I noticed was
like that there was a lock on the front
door was backwards and then all the
walks in the room to her backwards they
didn't lock me inside at all from the
outside
and then like I was like so I'm starting
to get sick like what's up and then was
the first time he hit me slapped me
across the face
he said [ __ ] I don't know what you
think this is but this is not like I'm
not giving you weren't given anything
here and he was like I'm gonna take you
over and gonna put you on the corner and
you're gonna work I said okay all right
and I just knew it I was and from there
I was in really big trouble I was about
22 I stayed with him for about two and a
half weeks with him like just give me a
little pieces of dope here and there
really sick all my money I gave him
every night anytime I like like I think
he just beat the crap out of us every
time you just felt like it or he was
upset or or he thought we were being
disrespectful
like she was just horrible horrible
person and he would block us in that
house all day all night until he wanted
us to go work and then take us out over
to Van Nuys and then about two and a
half weeks into it I got in a car with a
undercover police officer turned out to
be and I ended up getting arrested oh
it's a Pokemon victory in Van Nuys and I
went to jail and never saw him again I
asked the girls in jail where I could
get heroin really easily and like where
where I could go and they told me how to
get downtown to downtown Los Angeles and
I just remember getting off the train
and being really sick and walking up for
Street and seeing the tents and being
like what is going on what the heck whoa
this is insane
and I've been here ever since had you
ever picked up guys to make money before
you guys just walking down the street in
Phoenix just like I'm not screwing
around my friends I thank you you were
doing here yeah I was doing here unlike
heroin and I was homeless I was just
like like doing random boosting or
whatever I'd had a boyfriend who had
taking care of me for a long time so
what were you saying
16 boys are in here when I was 14 when I
start getting high um I grew up really
really poor on all those five kids um my
dad's an alcoholic my mom's a drug
addict and they were really really
absent um as we were growing up like I
raised my siblings like until I was like
18 and I left I was wondering like got
him up for school in the morning made
sure they eat dinner I mean when we had
when we had food I made later yeah
teenager yeah yeah definitely
um my parents basically after like the
kids were like newborns or whatever like
they would just stop showing up at home
like like four days at a time we
couldn't find them like the power would
get shut off every month after like
about a week or so because my
grandparents would think we'd have to
call my grandparents because like we
would be like literally starving and
like we wouldn't know where they were so
we have to call my grandparents they've
tracked down my parents and I've had to
come back to like a few days play a
parent role or whatever and then
disappear again for there's a month so
yeah do you stop contact with your
siblings um um
not really just cuz I'm getting high and
I don't want I've like caused enough
like turmoil and like heartbreak and
heart and like worry in their lives like
a not to like it's over again where you
saying I stay in a tent off of Crocker
and sevens yeah I was staying off six
and San Julian and then a month ago my
boyfriend went to jail and then I went
to jail about due date a day later or
whatever and then when I got out our
stuff was gone again so I got a new tent
and then I put it up over there what are
you
working the street
you typically denied your birthday at
night and they mostly yeah how much
money do you make
like nothing like about like on a really
good night I'll make like 120 bucks on
like a usual night downtown I'll make
like 50 60 bucks that's it
then you make sure we're using condoms
always always I don't want to I always
say I don't want to permanent
consequence off a temporary situation
you know I don't want I don't want to
end up like with HIV or AIDS I'm only 26
like I don't want to end up with HIV
like I tell the rest of my life you know
like and it's really prevalent down here
I know like a couple girls who have
gotten HIV like slipping down here
scary that's horrible
nobody grows up to be in five years you
think I'm going to a casino five years I
would like to be like happy
I'm just happy and comfortable and like
safe and secure like that's really it
like I don't care where I'm working or
what I'm doing as long as I'm happy you
know and like around people who like
really genuinely care for me because
around here nobody really cares about
you people just want what they can get
from you and and and there's a price to
pay for everything nothing around here
is free that's for sure do you think it
is about heroin addiction that blocks
you from getting your life together
getting taken responsibility to any job
and place to live in a car whatever they
need to just drain your energy to do
that any group no it just
it always comes first because you get
dope sick or whatever just no matter
what comes before everything because
you're just so afraid of getting sick
because once you get sick then it's over
like you can't function you can't hustle
you can't get money you can't do
anything yeah you can't do anything like
you're literally just like horribly
horribly sick so you'll do anything to
make sure that you don't get to that
point so like if you have to go to work
that day and and you're at a dope and
and you don't get paid til Friday you
got to figure out something today
like forget Friday you know it's too
much of a minute-by-minute day-by-day
drug
nope but I have like resuscitated an ark
and over like 15 people down here so zip
it down here is that something is a very
volatile barrel
yeah it's horrible because these people
like I tried to tell people like
fentanyl in the hospital is for Pete for
patients who are terminally ill who are
about to be about dying who are dying
and about to be you know dead and its
measured in micrograms it's not
measuring it up grams like people don't
understand that and it's like an
anesthetic like it like puts you to
sleep or whatever for surgery it's like
one of those drugs it's not I'm gonna to
get high off of it's not I've never
watched I would snort something and
overdose like that that was crazy to
mean this guy snorted some of it an
overdose created an Arcanum and do CPR
like that was insane like this is not
something to mess around with and then
people are like playing chemistry and
with the dope with the heroin and
putting it in there to make it like a
little bit stronger so they can make
more money and it's killing people and
they just don't care
it blows me away
video a young girl doing something like
I needed ballet for like 12 years and I
always wanted to go to like Juilliard or
be a ballerina and then if that didn't
work out I was gonna be a nurse and like
help people help people but I don't know
I just got so like after like like
raising my siblings and like like nobody
told me like hey felt these college
applications or hey take this test or
hey take these classes I didn't have any
guidance or any sort of direction so I
didn't end up doing any of it and then I
ended up getting like hooked on these
drugs and then after that it was a wrap
[Applause]
thank you it will be right one it will
be right
[Music]